if your world was plagued by terrifying
Devils what would you do you'll be
forced to fight an army of monsters in
order to get to the most powerful devil
of all and by the way not even your
teammates will be able to save you I'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
katana devil in chainsaw man part two
this human turned devil is going to
watch all of his teammates get
slaughtered by terrifying creatures in a
world where all human spheres have come
to life as Devils denji here has been
forced by the government to join this
devil hunting crew to track down and
kill the most powerful monster in the
world the gun devil a terrifying super
villain that has the power to kill
millions and will soon destroy the
entire world but all denji cares about
is scoring with a pretty girl
understandable this girl in particular
and he is determined to come out of this
job alive just to get a date with her
going through hell to find the gun devil
denji's team has just Fallen into a trap
set by one of its followers this
creature The Eternity devil it has
swallowed a piece of the gun Devil's
flesh and his powers have now been
enhanced Aki mentions that they need to
collect the gun Devil's flesh from
inside this Devil's stomach this is
their mission realizing that they are
now trapped within a pocket Dimension
and all out of options Benji out of
nowhere uses his devil powers and turns
into chainsaw men and he jumps down into
the black hole of this creature's
stomach and he tries to slaughter this
devil up into a million pieces but
realizes it's too powerful and he
realizes that he's losing too much blood
the blood loss causing him to turn
quickly back into his human form and his
chainsaw parts start to disappear The
Eternity devil then gets ready to eat
denji's valuable heart but this kid
realizes something insane and makes the
connection there's blood all around him
so he cuts slices and stabs The Eternity
devil again and again and begins to feed
on its blood fueling denji and making
his chainsaw powers in mind go
absolutely crazy turning full cycle and
he begins to savagely kill this Devil in
a way that no one has ever seen before
kimano here watches in horror and thinks
he might just be crazy enough to soon be
able to beat the gun devil what does
make sense is how not prepared this
group was for their mission and the
reason I bring that up is because of
what they carry to each job it's always
the same armored suits select Weaponry
contract with various devils and despite
their mission each time being so
different but even if they didn't know
what devil they were going to face this
time around there were ways that they
could have been better prepared
regardless at least if I was in charge
it's noted that we've been trapped
within this pocket dimension for days
but if we came into each devil hunting
job expecting the absolute worst
wouldn't it have been a good idea from
the start that we bring along with us an
assault pack or a military backpack that
could have easily kept us equipped with
all sorts of combat Essentials assault
packs are intended primarily for shorter
one to three day missions and can hold
around 20 liters because let's face it
we're basically glorified cops and on
top of that we're not up against any
regular bad guys not human beings oh no
no no we're going up against superpower
to Demons because of this it's insane
that we're dressed in suits yet we don't
carry any Essentials with us or Reserve
packs on duty the gang manages to
finally escape and collect another piece
of the gun Devil's flesh resembling a
bullet Aki says that once they collect
enough bullets these things will begin
to vibrate and direct them to the
location of the gun devil later they
decide to celebrate their small victory
at a bar how original and they discussed
that more Devils have started dying on
the job and this freaks some of the
rookies out not realizing that only some
of them will make it through this week
alive next to them kimano tells denji
that she owes him a kiss for taking out
the eternity devil earlier and he gets
really excited and group leader makima
finally shows up and the other guy who
likes his boss Aki tells makima that
there are more Devils with gun pieces
inside of them and they've started to
show up more frequently reminds them
that earlier The Eternity devil wanted
denji's heart too and isn't that strange
and so he asks makima if she knows
anything about this and makima looks him
dead in the face and says that she'll
tell him if they can out drink her so
the entire group faces off against her
but lose massively because makimo drinks
alcohol like a fish and in doing this
she manages to keep all her cards to
herself but himino has had enough of all
of this and plants a big one right on
denji's mouthpiece and he gets really
happy right as she unloads some very
warm romantic vomit right into his mouth
it's gross but later though he wakes up
in her apartment and she tries to get a
little freaking freaky and suddenly he
becomes all moral and chaste and says
that he wants to save himself or makima
and he tells her that the kiss earlier
was a mistake the next day denji
confesses his love for makima to himeno
and says how he wants to be with her and
since himano is a good friend she makes
a deal with denji she'll help him out
with makima if he helps her get the guy
that she really once Aki and now the two
partners in their romantic crime plan
their next move not realizing that soon
most of them will all be assassinated
okay we need to talk about the craziness
of this situation because how is the
world on the verge of being destroyed by
a terrifying devil and somehow these two
are talking about romantic cutesy stuff
which I'm actually super into because we
love love and while helping our team out
with their romance problems might seem
silly this could in fact help us win the
war against the Devils hear me out being
in love not only helps lower your stress
levels and better mental acuity oxytocin
can physically increase your tolerance
for physical pain and can build and
regenerate muscles at faster speeds
which means that dating each other as
teammates will make us happier smarter
cause drama and tear us all apart maybe
that's not a good idea that later makima
and her assistant head to Kyoto for a
meeting not to noticing the passengers
behind them suddenly disappear from view
makima's assistant asks her if she knows
why so many Devils have started to
appear with pieces of the gun Devil's
flesh side of them but she says that she
can't share that information with low
level betas ouch out of nowhere four men
surround them and blow their heads off
and instantly kill him the Killer's
radio and their team to begin the
operation and one by one all the devil
Hunters across Japan begin to get
slaughtered one by one nearby faint
sounds of gunfire rip through the
streets alerting denji's gang that there
is something going on of course what
does power think she thinks it's
fireworks and none of them know that
they are about to be in big trouble in a
matter of seconds continuing to eat in
this restaurant this stranger near them
suddenly makes a rude comment about the
taste of the ramen and calls Genji's
crew uncivilized for enjoying this
restaurant which Aki thinks it's rather
strange they watch him take out a photo
of his grandfather and reveals to denji
that he murdered his grandfather and
denji slow to realize this and this
killer aggressively pulls out his gun
and points it right at his face Aki and
power react fast and quickly managed to
subdue him pushing him out of the way
and Aki summons his contract to devil
Khan to Feast on his flesh blowing up
the entire building the destruction
causes himino to be critically injured
and power tends to her and Aki notices
denji hasn't healed yet but it gets
worse Khan alerts Aki that he's just put
something horrible in his mouth
something that is not human and not
devil and realizes that it's just made a
terrifying mistake and just then its
entire face gets sliced open by The
Stranger who's now transformed into
something far worse Katana man fueled up
on pure adrenaline Aki takes out his
devil sword and tries to attack this
unknown creature and manages to get some
good shots in switching up tactics he
then uses his sword to activate his
second and final contract devil the
cursed devil it terrifyingly picks up
Katana man and kills him on the spot and
Aki takes a breather and checks in on
his teammates but realizes that himano
is bleeding out and will die unless he
does something and just then a
mysterious blonde girl shows up near him
and she just casually walks over and and
revives Katana man and Aki looks on in
total disbelief and she gives this
monster for dying telling him to
kill them all and so Katana devil bends
over and supercharges himself up while
Aki gets ready for another round but
it's too late Anki suddenly notices
Katana man right behind him and realizes
what's just happened he's been stabbed
and he coughs up blood blonde girl tells
Katana man that Aki's devil Hunter suit
protected him and orders this monster to
finish the job kimono knows that she's
about to see her Crush her boo-boo die
and orders power here to do something
says that she can't even see Katana
man's moves and she bags her own
contract to devil this ghost hand to
attack but the devil says that the
blonde girl scares her desperate and now
out of time humano offers her contract
devil a new contract and sells her
entire soul in exchange in order to be
able to use this Devil's full Powers
right here right now and it accepts
flowing through humano she uses its
powers from hell and manifests into this
terrifying demon and brings it into to
existence Katana man changes his
attention and tries to fight back but
quickly gets overpowered and Aki notices
humano slowly dying off losing parts of
her body one at a time about to kill
Katana man everyone thinks they've saved
the day and out of nowhere blonde girl
suddenly calls up her own devil contract
the snake devil and it swallows humano's
devil rights in front of everyone's eyes
and hymno's Body and Soul disappears off
of the face of the Earth blonde girl
then orders Katana man to retrieve
chainsaw man's heart but himano's ghost
10 about to disappear uses the last bit
of its strength to hover over and pull
on chainsaw Man's Chest Reviving him
instantly and these freaky looking dudes
get ready to go at it whoa this is about
the biggest show since the ending
of King's game however though there are
a few things that don't make sense and
reveals how again unprofessional this
team really is including the leader
makima she's not that great we've seen
that she has great interest in denji
only and it makes no sense why no one on
her team bothered to do a background
check on the guy that she so obsessed
with he's a poor kid doing jobs for
gangs and he just murdered a bunch of
Yakuza members including a Yakuza boss
or at least he might as well have since
they were all dead and he was left
holding the Smoking Gun or this case
chainsaw and this fact alone should have
put makima and her team on alert being
involved in Yakuza business means that
it's obvious that someone was going to
try to kill denji sooner or later and
that should have spelled trouble for
anyone that would have been in close
proximity to him all they had to do was
a simple background check on denji and
that would have let him know that his
affiliations were criminal and he had a
lot of baggage and if they still wanted
to bring him on great but at very least
it would have made this team more aware
of any potential threats from Genji's
past that were eventually going to catch
up with him and getting over to himano
her death while it seems epic as hell it
just wasn't necessary or even practical
it's noted that denji was brought back
to life just now by having his chest
Court getting pulled on by human before
she died but it doesn't make sense why
she didn't do that before she gave up
her life for no reason she was is
already in close proximity to denji at
the time and could have revived him like
this way earlier and especially when you
consider that earlier Against The
Eternity devil she did the same thing to
him when he died which means she already
knew about this move and means as a
veteran devil Hunter she failed her
training and panic and sacrificed
herself for no real reason oh that's
right love that's not good enough
springing back up with life chainsaw man
pounces on Katana man and the two engage
in a brutal combat slicing and dicing
each other ending up on the streets
blonde hair girl calls for backup and to
some of her minions try to shoot
chainsaw man and he takes a bad guy
hostage but Katana man then uses his
supercharge to move a final time and
cuts a Genji in half killing him again
and now with the battle finally
seemingly over he transforms back into
his human form sideburned Guy original
name I know meanwhile back in machimus
train the bad guys find out that the
train will be arriving in Kyoto shortly
and they get ready with their escape
plans once they reach it but they have
no idea they will never leave this train
alive and then sudden appears behind
them and looks completely unharmed and
she smiles and the bad guy Scream
minutes later at Kyoto station a few
double Hunter advisors wait for makima's
arrival but get word that the rest of
the devil Hunter division has been
ambushed right as Magma's train finally
arrives and they're nervous and she
steps out these two are shocked but she
tells them to not worry because she's
fine she tells them that the bad guys
are most likely after denji as she
prepares her plan to save him and she
orders her advisors to gather 30
convicts serving life sentences or more
and to gather them at a shrine on a
nearby Mountain they're super confused
but she tells them that she'll deal with
the dentist situation from here reaching
the shrine makima changes into some
clean clothes just as the prisoners
arrive blindfolding everyone doing this
to ensure that no one knows what Devils
she has contracts with and what does she
do my good weebs hmm she starts
sacrificing convicts one by one using
her unknown devil contracts to act
activate even more Bloodshed back in
Kyoto sideburns guy and blonde girl try
to kidnap denji in this truck but
suddenly one of their minions start
feeling a little weird and he says he
feels strange and realizes something is
wrong but rather than he gets crushed by
an unknown force and blonde girl
realizes that makima must be behind this
and radios her team to check if she's
really dead and won by one all of her
minions die off others try to run away
but explode and then blonde girl notices
one of denji's teammates up ahead hair
clip girl and she's alive and pissed off
blonde hair girl calls on her snake
devil but hair clip girl is too quick
and Dodges its attack and charges at
them she cuts off Sideburn guy's hand
and shields herself with the dengie's
corpse from the blonde girls attack now
out of devil energy Sideburn Sky
Retreats into a van while blonde girl
drives them off to escape without denji
or his heart and hair clip girl cries of
the loss of her teammates later devil
Hunter advisors meet up with makima back
in Tokyo and they report that most all
of the members have been killed makima
thinks that this is the work of the gun
devil and her reasoning beings that due
to Japan's strict gun loss it's very
likely the gun devil probably supplied
all these bad guys with the weapons this
advisor tells makima that the rest of
the devil hunting divisions have now
joined together into one unit and they
tell makima that she'll be running the
show fearing for his life this scaredy
cat gives off classic glasses guy energy
and tells makima that he wants to quit
the team a few days later Aki wakes up
in the hospital all heartbroken over
himano's death and denji tells him that
most of their members are dead or have
ended up quitting because this job is
getting too dangerous and he leaves with
power right as Aki takes out his cursed
devil's sword and receives some bad news
from this contract to devil because he
wasted his devil power on Katana man
earlier his remaining lifespan on Earth
has now been reduced to two years he
tries to light a match but remembers his
old partner and breaks down in sadness
and in pain and denji overhears outside
but wonders why he himself is not crying
and he realizes that even though they
were friends he's not really even that
sad about himino's death and his
emotions have started to disappear more
and more since he got turned into a
double hybrid and he wonders what will
happen if he soon to become more devil
than human but he quickly forgets about
all of those serious thoughts and goes
on with his happy merry day back in
Aki's room the same devil Hunter advises
from earlier show up they consult Aki
and tell him that since he abused one of
his Devils from earlier that he had a
contract with Khan it likely won't ever
let him use its powers again they also
say that the cursed Temple located in
his sword this devil will only let him
use its powers a few more times before
his contract with it expires as well
they advise him that he needs to make
some new contracts with some more Devils
or else he won't survive the incoming
battles against the gun devil and they
warn him that he's about to go through
hell if he stays on this job they tell
him that he can retire if he wants to
wanting to avenge his ex-partner though
and his family which died by the gun
devil he decides to stay on the job and
the advice is prepared to hook him up
with some really sweet terrifying double
contracts and they leave right as this
lady enters and Aki is shocked it's
humano's sister and she handsome letter
sent to her by Humana over the years
detailing her and Aki's adventures
together and he finds out that she was
in love with him that she wanted to
eventually quit the devil hunting life
for good making him feel even more sad
and feeling him with some spicy
character motivation moving on later
denji and power meet up with makima in
this creepy cemetery and she tells them
her new crazy plan due to the recent
attacks it's clear by now that the bad
guys are after denji which means that he
needs to learn how to better defend
himself even more and she tells them
that this blonde hair guy will now put
them through training to turn them into
even more lethal devil Hunters he's kind
of creepy and asks how these two felt
when their teammates died but dengian
Power say they didn't really care about
it too much but they were fine and blood
guy then smiles and says that they'll
make perfect devil Hunters someday if
they survive his training and he
announces that their training will start
now and goes to to hug them in a really
weird way and mentions that he's a devil
hunter that loves his job women and
alcohol and suddenly he squeezes them a
little too hard and crushes their spine
and tells them that their strength lies
in the fact that they can regenerate
instantly with blood but if they go
against the gun devil they'll need to
become much stronger and he offers them
his most insane challenge yet and gives
them permission to try and kill him
tenji and power think he's crazy but
blonde guy begins to approach them and
these two quickly try to defend
themselves and attack but this badass
boss man swiftly kills them again in one
smooth go and blonde guy insults their
skills really repeatedly and tells them
that he'll keep trying to kill them
every day until they become better
Killers themselves a little while later
on the way back home a super tired denge
in power think about running away from
their job since it's no fun anymore a
power out of nowhere thinks she has an
idea and tells denji that blonde guy is
a certified drunk and that alcohol has
likely rotted his brain and they should
use this fact to their advantage in
instead of trying to fight head-on they
should use their smarts instead of
strength to win against him when they
fight him tomorrow and they begin
scheming the next day blonde guy shows
up at their apartment and the Bloodshed
begins again trying to open Genji's
front door power suddenly throws a spear
right through it forcing him to quickly
Dodge it and switching to plan B she
desperately shoots her blood-filled
bottles above him to spear him down
through the floor and doesn't realize
his sick evasive moves denji quickly
surprises him from behind but gets
properly knocked in the face now both
down bad blonde guy critiques their
performance he says that other power you
used up too much of your blood and
became anemic and weak and did you mad
good man you failed to predict my attack
and that he calls it a day and leaves so
then denji gets up and calls out to
check on power but then suddenly gets
stabbed in the hand confused he looks up
and sees blonde guy who tells them that
they should never trust the words of a
hunter okay this is crazy and while
these two did try to use their tiny
brains to combat this devil haunting
serial killer their efforts were really
wasted if I was then the first thing
that I would have done would have been
to look into who this guy really was and
not show up and meet him in person prior
because he clearly gave us a long enough
of Head Start to prepare this guy is the
strongest member of the devil hunters
and his calm attitude means that he
knows that anyone that fights him head
on is probably going to die and him
being the best means it's clear that
this guy fighting fair and square is out
of the question because we're Devils
after all it means that we need to fight
him dirty this is why I would have tried
to use the combination of the element of
surprise and 10 milliliters of pure
ethanol methanol my good weebs is a
colorless liquid that occurs naturally
at a low level in most alcoholic
beverages however though industrial
methylated Spirits used for things like
cleaning or thinning solvent but this
thing is extremely toxic and when
consumed even a little 10 milliliters
can destroy the optic nerve and can very
quickly cause blindness and by the way
this can be bought in most places
meanwhile Aki meets with his devil
hunting advisors and they go down to
this secret basement and they tell him
that this is where their organization
keeps all the Devils that that they
capture on the job and this is where
devil hunting members can make different
deals with them and soon Aki with his
only two years left of life will be able
to soon face off against the gun devil
and his minions he just needs to be as
strong as possible to do it but they
warn him and saying that the stronger
the devil that he makes the deal with
the more terrifying his contract to
receive that power will be and they've
finally reached the basement and tell
him that the organization wants him to
make a deal with one of their top Devils
the future devil one of the most
powerful devils in existence but to
obtain a contract from it Aki will need
to be prepared to suffer they reveal
that two other members currently have
contracts with this devil and that one
sacrificed half their lifespan to use
his powers and the other gave up all of
their senses but this guy tells him that
if the devil likes him he might make his
contract less terrifying opening this
steel cage door Aki heads inside and
steps into the darkness and watches
something watch him back Aki sees the
future devil emerged from the Shadows
but it turns out to be a total dance
saying weirdo it tells him that the
details of Aki getting a contract with
him will depend on what future he has he
tells Aki to plop his face inside of it
while it scans his future and so he
takes a quick sec to look at Aki's fate
and that's when it suddenly laughs like
a devil it tells Aki that it will allow
him to use his powers if it can live
inside of his eye and it tells Aki that
he will die in the most painful way
possible in the future and because of
this it wants to get a front row view of
his death when it happens but Aki
doesn't care about the future and
accepts the future Devil's contract
telling him that he'll do whatever it
takes to kill as many Devils as he can
within that time meanwhile blonde guy
keeps training denji in power the only
way that he knows how which is to try to
straight up kill them every single time
and mentions though that they've gotten
better but reveals to them that they'll
soon face real terrifying combat
tomorrow and he lays out their upcoming
Mission and their targets Katana man and
blonde girl capture or kill but if they
fail their devil hunting division will
be finished and they will likely be put
down like dogs by blonde guy and he'll
make it hurt he says later that night
blonde guy has dinner with makima and
she compliments his training with denji
and power but he says that each time one
of his trainees dies he dranks a little
more and mentions that he's worried
about their upcoming battle tomorrow he
then asks makima about the Ambush and
the recent deaths of most of the devil
Hunters telling her that the bosses who
run the government aren't stupid and he
asks magma if she knew about the
assassinations beforehand and blonde guy
states that as long as she is on the
side of humans he doesn't care what
terrifying things she does but she tells
him that all she wants to do is to save
people from Devils blonde guy calls her
a big fat liar and she lets out a faint
smile the next day sideburns guy and
blonde girl hide out in this building
and get ready for battle this minion
tells them that they've moved the big
boss to another Hideout but blonde girl
says as long as makima is alive there
will be nowhere to hide in Japan
sideburns guy here is granddad's little
boy and tells everyone that his old man
would never run from trouble anymore
forces everybody to buckle up for the
most bloody battle they are all about to
join in he reveals to them that they
have a secret weapon hidden underneath
this building a bunch of zombies ooh how
original and this is how they'll take
out denji's crew meanwhile makima shows
up this house in the forest home to
sideburn's guy's boss and she finds out
from him that they did not order the
recent hit on all the devil hunters in
Japan but that blonde girl was the one
behind us an ex-member she'd been
tricking young gang members into making
contracts with the gun devil in exchange
for 20 000 Yen they'd all get access to
the gun Devil's unlimited weapons but
machima remains emotionless and asks
this Yakuza boss to write down all the
names of all the members who have
contracts with the gun devil but the
boss man laughs and tells her that
giving all the names will create a war
within Japan among the crime syndicates
and if this happened this will make
Japan weak and this will result in
foreign Mafia taking over Japan makima
that gives him a package containing the
eyeballs of everyone's family members in
this room and this shocks everyone and
this Yakuza tries to to attack a machima
but then has a nosebleed and he dies
right there she then gets up and tells
the yak is a boss that the most
necessary evils in this world are always
run by the state meanwhile back in Tokyo
denji's team has finally surrounded the
building where the bad guys are and the
good guys prepare for Bloodshed blonde
guy tells Aki and the team that there is
no plan they're just gonna go in there
and assault this building okay so these
people are about to go storm this
terrifying building in the same manner
as Bruce Willis did in Die Hard One
awesome but stupid doing the thing
without a plan and going balls to the
wall and while it may look badass this
is really dumb if this mission was so
important and for the good of the city
it makes no sense to send in just a few
devil hunters and ones that you've been
training why not send the hole to hang
Army in any case if I was them I would
not only storm the entrance of the
building but I would also Storm from the
rooftop as well as both sides enter
doing this would have forced the enemy
to be cornered on both sides and
surprised them by attacking the enemy
from above and below which would force
them to not rely on any pre-existing
defenses and basically Panic invading
the building this shark fiend devil
swims through this basement and begins
attacking all of these zombies and he
teams up with a few others just like him
the violence fiend this devil likes
humans along with this angel devil Aki
bumps into her and hands her
handkerchief this impresses her and she
asks if Aki isn't afraid of having his
life span absorbed from her and he says
he doesn't care and they kill this one
bad guy and he tells denji and power
here to split up and go floor by floor
to clear the building Aki Sprints
through these floors but begins to watch
every bad guy die by nosebleeds it's
strange and he can't explain what's
going on he then reaches this staircase
but that's when he comes across blonde
girl she then makes her snake devil
appear and it spits out jimeneo's devil
now under blonde hair grows control but
then also her nose suddenly starts
bleeding but she doesn't think much of
it and she makes this devil attack Aki
but he quickly uses the future Devil's
powers to see a few seconds into the
future allowing him to dodge all of
these attacks but not for long he
finally gets caught and injured and is
about to be killed and this ghost gets
ready to kill denji and chokes him he
then passes out and pictures him and
himino and begins to have no fear of
death or this ghost suddenly though this
causes this devil to drop him and it
offers him something in its hand Aki
picks up the cigarette and realizes that
it belonged to himino and that's when he
smiles and picks up his sword climbing
over this devil and blonde girl looks in
shock now without fear he kills this
devil and gets ready to arrest blonde
girl she tries to call her snake devil
again but gets held up at knife points
by hair clip girl meanwhile dungeon
power take the lift up and get ready for
the incoming Bloodshed power starts
chomping on a snack and denji is really
disgusted the two then get into their
100th fight as this lift door opens up
and they see a zombie horde heart
pumping denji tells power to keep her
voice down but suddenly power yells at
the top of her lungs instigating trouble
and shocking denji she says that they
can take them on and charge his head on
like an idiot and denji just leaves her
to die slicing and dicing these flesh
eaten bastards she cuts this giant
zombie head off and it spurts out
delicious blood back in the lift Dungey
keeps going up and arrives on the 13th
floor and it gets ready to transform
into chainsaw man but that's when he
comes across sideburns guy and he offers
for them to talk it says that they're
willing to surrender if denji apologizes
for killing his Yakuza Granddad then he
gets really annoyed and says that he
only killed him because he was already a
zombie sideburns guy thinks that Dengue
lying and starts to get really mad he
wants to know if denji felt guilty for
killing them but denji tells them no
then sideburn's guy then reveals to
denji that blonde hair girl replaced his
heart with the katana Devil's heart but
even he thinks that denji has become too
cold he offers denji to let him give
denji a quick death and denji thinks
about it for a quick sec and says no
thank you and both flip on their switch
and suddenly transform into bloodthirsty
Killers blasting out of this building
the two clashed blades in hot steel as
they come crashing down and denji Dodges
a bunch of attacks but his forcibly
pushed back and gets slammed down
further into this passing train
sideburns guy AKA Katana man catches up
with him and commends him on his new
fighting skills but they won't be enough
it asks denji what he's really fighting
for and he says that he likes his life
and says that he has food at home and a
pretty girl that will soon be his
girlfriend Katana man calls him an idiot
and tells him that he can't beat him
they charge at each other but then she
gets knocked back and begins to realize
that he's running out of steam Katana
man super jumps into the air and comes
crashing down into denji and they reach
the passenger floor everyone begins to
run as the train starts coming to an
emergency stop denji tries to catch his
breath but that's when he notices Katana
man crouched down and denji knows what
that means he tries to block it but gets
one of his arms ripped clean off and
Katana man spams his attack buttons to
get denji a second time now with no arms
Katana man demands that denji apologized
for killing his granddad before he dies
but denji refuses Furious Katana man
prepares his signature move for a final
time but it's already too late the head
of dengue chainsaw finally cracks Katana
man tells denji that it's over and that
he can't fight anymore but neither can
he Katana man's body splits apart as his
organs and guts paint the window in red
hot thick blood and the stench of his
corpse begins to fill the train with
Sweet Victory okay while that was a
sweet fighting sequence I loved it
Benji's Victory here was really not that
impressive because despite all of the
cool moves he cared for using a special
attack again and again and again to the
point where his moves became painfully
obvious but another thing that doesn't
make sense was how denji and his team
was not informed of katana man's biggest
weakness and this was the fact that if
we noticed from earlier once he changed
back into a human he was unable to
transform back into his devil because if
he could then he would have when he
faced against hair clip girl since there
was no reason for him in that moment to
be human if hair clip girl was paying
attention it wasn't such a crybaby she
could have noticed this major flaw and
could have alerted denji's Team later
sideburn's guy wakes up and realizes
that he's been chained up by denji he
tells this bad guy that because of what
he did to his friends Dungy will now
kick him in the nuts in honor of his
Fallen comrades but that's when Aki
shows up and looks down on denji's
silliness but denji tells Aki to let
loose man for once in your life think of
himino so convinced now Aki joins in on
the fun and they ready they're kicking
while Sideburn Sky radies his onigiris
meanwhile magma goes to report to her
big boss and informs him of today's
events she tells him that the
assassinations were committed by the
blonde girl who was the next devil
Hunter herself and she wanted denji's
heart and the big boss asks why she
wanted denji's heart specifically but
she tells him that before they could
find out that information she
mysteriously died from her own contract
devil and she tells him how they also
obtained 1.4 kilos of the gun Devil's
flesh from inside the bad guy's building
and now the flesh has started to point
them to the location of the gun devil
but what do you guys think about the
video let us know what you like about it
and what you didn't like about it don't
forget to like subscribe and leave a
thumbs up down below and as always check
out our how to be playlist